every few days for the past 18 months
Muhammad hajarat has visited the
cemetery in the small Israeli Village of
beer al-maxor
to pray and to talk to his young son
Amar just four years old he was shot and
killed last January
it's very difficult he told us and the
pain has not passed
it hasn't changed the grief is greater
now every day before bed I stare at the
ceiling and think about Amara
criminal gangs and gun violence have
caused heartache like this across many
Palestinian villages in Northern Israel
including here in ibilin
any one of us could be shot whether
we're in our neighborhoods the school a
hospital the mosque in the street but I
never imagined this would happen to my
family ola's brother Bilal narrowly
survived three bullets from a motorbike
Gunman's automatic weapon that missed
its intended target the police
investigation is slow
the police only approached us when we
asked them to meet four or five days
after the incident
her parents used to leave their front
door unlocked at night but not anymore
researchers call the violence an
epidemic if we thought it was an
emergency two years ago now it's just
mind-blowing what is happening some
analysts blame High rates of youth
unemployment and economic disparities I
don't think that there's an Arab family
that doesn't
know or actually have a casualty from
shooting or from crime in Israel prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu said
recently support would come from the
intelligence agency Shin Bet
we're determined to end this wave of
murders we will do this not only by
boosting the police but also with the
assistance of the Shin Bet but
Palestinian Israeli politicians insist
that's not a serious solution
violence and crime levels have increased
more than 300 percent so this is
evidence that government policies and
leaders are not interested in dealing
with the issue of violence and crime in
Arab Society
for Muhammad his anger has grown
alongside his grief
I hold the state responsible the heads
of the state they are capable of finding
the person who killed Amar
questions unanswered investigations
unfinished pain unending
villain marks Al Jazeera Israel